(hum)
- Just want you guys to know,
I been grinding for three hours, but
DRock overslept so it wasn't documented.
You're (word silenced)
up my hustle, DRock.
(bell rings)
Don't (word silenced)
with my hustle, DRock.
- [Voiceover] What was that?
("Used To" by Genesis Elijah)
(traffic noise)
- [Gary] It's a nice
day in the neighborhood.
That's him.
- Stan's up?
- [Gary] Yep.
- Alright, good luck.
- [Gary] Thanks.
("Used To" by Genesis Elijah)
- Vaynerchuk!
(sighs) No, feeling really good.
I talked to him about that,
I talked to him about musical.ly,
and then I looked at him and I said,
you've just got more value on this scope
in the last hour than you did for
(beep) whole year, didn't you?
And he looked at me and he said,
"That's why I'm here."
I'm being selfish with
this piece of content.
I want to point to this piece
of content my whole life,
because it gets brought up every so often
and I just want to clear it forever.
Like, just, I've zero,
zero, zero intent
to tell people that this is
the way you have to do it.
I have no interest, none, zero,
for you to do it my way.
I'm not trying to tell you how to do it.
I'm just trying to tell you how I do it
so that you can use it as
a North Star to proxy,
and you should navigate around it.
You know, you're only
getting truly exposed now
to how much work it really is.
To how hard I really go.
And I get that it's intense,
and I get that it's exhausting,
and I get that it can
be boring and mundane.
Well, guess what?
That's what it is.
It's a constant grind.
It is a forever, grinding
, day-in-and-day-out,
same shit, pound it.
Problems. Meetings.
Everyday, always, forever.
I'm sorry I can't show you a lot of looks.
Good, I have some good news.
There's some new looks coming.
DRock's about to travel
his (word silenced) off
with me on this book tour.
And you know what you're
going to see in Australia,
and you know what you're going to see in
all these other places?
The same (word silenced).
The grind. The hustle.
Mike, just trying to always move the ball,
you know what I mean?
Trying to get it past the
goal line, and if not,
just make sure we moved it.
Meetings that are a complete waste of time
are devastating, and so if I feel
like we're not getting
anywhere, I get rogue.
I get angry, and I just
try to move the ball.
Like, make sure that we only have
one more meeting after this,
'cause that's it.
Just, no tolerance.
So we're pumped to do my first TV spot
for the new book.
I think, I think, the airs on
the day the book comes out,
you know, but that could be breaking news.
Going to do Doctor Oz show.
My jam.
How do you talk to an angel?
Thank you.
- [Woman] We're going to take
you right to set,
just for a rehearsal.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Voiceover] Hi!
- And I'm excited.
It's a different audience.
You know, it's a lot of daytime-watching,
stay-at-home types.
You know, it will be really interesting
to see how they consume the energy,
the content, and the strategies,
so, they're really doing right by me.
Three segments, half the show.
Should be pretty good. My mom's pumped.
That always makes me happy, so...
Let's see what we do.
- [Voiceover] It's going
to be a great show!
Are you ready for a great time
for the Oz Show everybody?
(crowd cheers and claps)
Give it up for Doctor Oz, right there.
- Oz time.
Oz time.
(crowd claps and cheers)
- [Voiceover] And here's
your friend, Gary.
- [Voiceover] Big (mumbles), Big Gary.
(announcer addresses crowd)
(crowd claps and cheers)
- [Gary] I'm proud that
I'm here with you today.
I get it.
I understand for a few
minutes, and then you're going
to home, and you're like, yeah!
And then it's next Thursday,
and you forgot this segment, right?
The bottom line is, there's so much
to gain from failures.
(crowd cheers)
(announcer addresses crowd)
- That's that.
- [DRock] That's good.
- Back to the grind, DRock.
(man laughs)
VaynerMedia's future home, coming in July.
What did you say?
- It is.
- [Woman] Do you hate that
or do you love it?
- [Gary] Hate it.
(woman laughing)
Anchor has been super, super buggy for me,
so just testing if it works.
Michael and crew, I love
the Jersey/New York hustle,
but I'm telling you right
now, if this doesn't work,
I'm going to be (word silenced) pissed.
(siren)
Random statement on Anchor,
mainly because I don't
think it's going to work
because I just tried to do a test
and it didn't fucking work.
So what do I want to say?
I peed my bed until I was 12.
Random fun fact.
12 years old.
You're almost like a grown (word
silenced) man at that point
and I'm still peeing my bed
in the middle of the night.
Think about that.
And I turned out okay.
So don't be scared about what happens
in the first 12 years
of your life (laughs).
Spiker, I just have a real quick question.
Is your real name Spiker?
Because if it is, I'm really
(word silenced) pissed,
because if my name was Spiker Vaynerchuk,
I think I'd be at least
four-x more successful.
Let me know if your real name's Spiker.
I'm just, I really don't think it is,
but if it is, (word beeped out).
Anchor could be dangerous.
Preventing speculation
is owning your medium
in this world, you know what I mean?
Like...
How are you doing?
- [Man at Desk] Good.
How are you?
- They keep moving you around.
- Yeah, they're gonna redo the lobby.
- Here?
- Yeah, (words drowned
by background music).
(Gary nickers)
- [Gary] Phil?
- [Matt] Right here.
- Gary.
- [Matt] Talk to you right now.
- You, you. Yes, Gabe.
Yes, Gabe.
(man mumbles to Gary)
- [Voiceover] Hey, brother.
- [Gary] Hey, brother.
- We can go in there.
Just wanted to strategize
about bottom drawer.
(man laughs)
- [Gary] What I mean by that
is something gets canceled,
this is on your priority
list, you know what I mean?
(man says something quietly to Gary)
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Voiceover] Okay, that's
a little different, so
you've got one sentence--
- [Voiceover] Ah, alright.
- I was flabbergasted.
Interesting, right?
(people chat)
Matt?
We're waiting, I want to wait for Alex.
Cool, here he is.
Jus beecause, like,
you're going to see this.
It's 90 minutes--
- [Gary] No, no.
I know what that is.
- [Matt] Okay, cool.
- What's this, Monday?
- [Matt] Yep.
Hmm?
Thanks, boss.
- [Voiceover] Do you need to be there?
It's the chief brand officer, the CEO--
- [Gary] Oh. it's that dude?
- Yeah.
- Okay, cool. That's it.
Thank you. Sorry.
Get to Wine Library,
we'll film at 1:45, 2:00.
Alright.
Yeah, you're going to
have to turn it around
right then and there.
We'd do no tech. We do no editing.
- [DRock] Right.
- That's the beauty
of Wine Library TV.
Episode 1001.
Hey man, I'm coming to
Wine Library tomorrow
to film episode 1001 because
it's the 10-year anniversary
of Wine Library TV on Sunday.
Cool. So I'll see you around 1:30.
I'm bringing Misha, too.
Hello everybody, and
welcome to Wine Library TV.
I am your host, Gary Vaynerchuk,
and this, my friends, is the Thunder Show,
a.k.a. the Internet's
most passionate wine program.
- Teo, were you banned?
- [Man with Beard] I'm sorry.
- [Gary] Hold on one second.
- He's suspended.
- [Man with Beard] I'm sorry.
- And we just had a talk.
- [Man with Beard] I screwed up.
- [Gary] Why did you, why were you late?
- (laughs) I was, I was in
a meeting late last night.
- [Gary] In a meeting?
- Yes, and I agree--
- [Gary] It's not a--
- [Man with Beard] I wanted to--
- Impress me?
- [Man with Beard] Yes.
- And instead, you failed me.
- [AJ] And instead he failed.
- [Gary] We could have used (mumbles).
You know, good rebounder.
- [Man With Beard] Yeah.
I'm not stopping.
- [Man with Glass] Where's
DJ Khaled when I need him?
(Gary laughs)
So congratulations.
- Hey, bro.
- [Ari] Hey Gary, can I get
five minutes of your time?
- Everybody wants five minutes
like they think it's nothing.
Like, five minutes is a lot around here.
- [Voiceover] Yo, let's get back--
- [Ari] I just want to
say, I hope you're having
a great day.
- Thanks, Ari.
- [Ari] It will be five
minutes (laughs).
- Guys, there was
something I wanted to okay,
which is this comment thing.
What is it?
(woman laughs)
Yes.
- [Foreground Woman] Okay.
- [Man in Black] For real.
- Yes, do it.
Zak, did you notice that,
did you notice on my page?
Do you see I day trade
attention and build businesses?
Scroll down. Gary Vee Builds Businesses.
- All the businesses. Cool.
- Businesses and businesses
and businesses and businesses.
Businesses and businesses and (splutters).
- That's our new audio track, by the way.
- We're going to do more
notes, and it's going to be fun
to see when all the other
pages start doing more notes.
(Gary laughs)
- Sid's here?
(man and woman exclaim)
What?
But Sid's here.
- [Sid] Hey, how are you going?
- Nice to see you, man.
I see him later?
Alright, get out of here (laughs)
- [Ari] Gary.
- Ari, you just said you
wanted me to have a good day.
You just literally.
- [Ari] I know, I know.
- DRock, what's the timestamp on that?
It was literally 20
(word silenced) seconds.
- I'm having lunch with (word beeped out).
- Great.
- [Ari] Any, any--
- Yeah, tell him, thanks,
I'm on the Shaq podcast.
- [Ari] Okay.
- And tell him (words beeped)
(people chat)
Oh, what? We're done.
- [Matt] We need to,
no we're not.
This is for 29th of Februrary.
We have to go through April, brother.
- I don't know, there's a lot.
I'm not in the zone right now.
- (laughs) I know you're like
super-pumped about Australia.
- I'm pumped just to (words beeped out)
Australia for eight hours.
- But you've got to (words beeped out)
Cleveland right out there (laughs)
- New York to Australia to Cleveland.
Yes, Robert.
How long am I there, really?
Eight hours?
- Go back.
- Oh, it's like eleven hours.
- But go to the next day.
No, I mean the previous day.
So, it's longer than eight hours.
- Nice. Are we doing
something in Honolulu?
Like a meet-up?
(sniffs)
Okay.
Hey, Chlo.
- [Woman] How are you?
- [Gary] Good.
I think banner programmatic
ads are worse than television.
I truly believe that
banner ads on websites
are a bigger blind spot
than a commercial on TV.
I don't think it's even close.
- [Man in Suit] Yeah.
DRock can you catch that, audio-wise?
Good, because I want to
make a video about that.
- [Woman] You like analogies.
- Me? I live on them.
It's literally my,
I would say it's my core way
to communicate to the world.
It's probably also why
I did well with Twitter.
It fit that kind of form of communication.
- [Woman] Oh, I'm so excited to read this.
- Yeah, you'll like it because
it's not a technology book.
It's just a 360
entrepreneurial mindset book.
Love being so aligned.
Talk to you later.
- [Man at Door] Hey, are you ready for me?
- [Gary] I am.
- [Man at Door] Awesome.
I know I'm preaching, I'm
just reconvincing myself
that that's my belief (laughs).
- Great.
The good news is, unlike most places
you've probably worked in your life,
you don't need to fight for it.
It's literally what I'm sitting here
telling you is about to happen.
- You were in my head
before I even knew it.
- Good. Good.
That's what I try to do.
Stay well.
Coming to London on, Alex.
- [Alex] March 23rd.
- March 23rd. I don't know my schedule.
Cool.
'sup everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
My book drops today.
Ah, 97-9, the box?
Ishmael, what's up, man, it's Gary Vee.
Thank you so much for
the Spanish subtitles.
Ishmael, you literally unlocked an entire
different subset of
individuals who'd never know
what I'm up to or what I'm talking about.
Thank you so, so, so, so, so, so, so much.
What's up social media managers?
It's me, Gary Vaynerchuk.
Leave it, leave it.
- [Man in White] Because we want to--
- [Gary] Leave it. I can talk.
Yeah, and I can talk about it.
- [Man in White] Okay, cool.
Hello.
(crowd greets Gary)
- [Unidentified Woman]
How you raise the plane?
- [Unidentified Man] Gary,
we just watched it together.
- This?
- [Unidentified Man] Yeah.
- Great, so I can just talk about it?
- [Unidentified Man] Yep.
- Got it.
Let me take a step back.
So, I think this is the television.
And I think this is the radio.
And I think today is 1965
and I believe it with
every piece of my heart.
And I believe that Facebook and Snapchat
and Instagram and YouTube
are ABC, NBC, and CBS, in 1965.
And I think what our job, as a company, is
to help (word beeped out)
and (beep) and (beep)
become MASH and Seinfeld
and Dynasty, right?
That's how I see the world.
If you think about the great filmmakers
or the people that produced music videos,
they had a style. Right?
It wasn't, they didn't patent anything.
It was a style.
I want our style to be really
good (word silenced) stories
that are as long as they
need to be to be told.
That's it.
That's the only (word beeped
out) that I care about.
And as you're ideating,
I don't know who's the equipment manager,
and who's the (word beeped out) producer.
I don't even know any of the titles yet
of what this is supposed to be,
but I want everybody here,
regardless of what you do,
to be thinking about that.
That when you see something
in your day-to-day
as a normal human, that made
you interested or intrigued,
you need to think about why that happened
and can that be applied for us to create
the cadence and the style of
the modern-day commercial.
Cool.
Any questions?
Actually, that may be fun.
Do we have a few minutes? Do we?
No?
(crowd laughs)
Alright. Good to see ya.
Thanks guys.
(people chat)
Hey, we have a meeting?
- [Unidentified Man] Yeah.
- [Gary] Great. Let's do it.
- [Man in Suit] Hey, Gary.
- [Gary] Good to see you again, my friend.
- [Man in Suit] Likewise.
- [Gary] How you been?
- [Man in Suit] (mumbles),
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Such a pleasure.
- [Man in Black Jacket] Thank you.
- Smells good in here.
Lot of good cologne or something.
I'm excited.
This is the best this room,
it's the best this room's smelled in years.
Is there coffee?
- I think it's your candies there.
- I don't think so.
They're always here and it
smells like (word beeped out).
And now it smells (words
beeped out) tremendous in here.
(people laugh)
So.
Well, it's a real pleasure.
- I have to perform.
I'm a performer.
If I don't perform, I have nothing to eat
at the end of the month.
It's really difficult nowadays
to build a new fashion brand.
Specially because everything's already
in the marketing system.
You cannot come in with something new.
So at the end of the
day, what are we selling?
We're selling emotion,
we're selling dreams.
We're selling a lifestyle.
We're selling a concept.
We don't do it for money,
we do it for, you know.
- [Man in Grey] Passion.
- For passion
and for other things.
- Legacy.
This entire company wants to figure out
how to communicate on this.
So we think that this is the television
and the television is the radio.
And so, we think Facebook,
Twitter, Snapchat,
Instagram, and YouTube
is like ABC, NBC, CBS.
The big networks in the
early days of television.
And then what we do is, whether
it's (words beeped out),
or whether it's a fashion brand,
we want to be the number
one show on those platforms.
And that's all we spend our time on.
Nothing else.
Because that's how you make money.
When you don't waste it.
We'll talk. We'll talk. We'll talk.
(people chat)
- [Matt] Here, (mumbles) got to
talk to you about something.
(people chat)
- [Gary] Let's go.
Fine.
(packet crinkles)
- [Man with Bottle] But if you're dying--
- Nah, I can grind.
- Do you want this?
- [Gary] No, but I'll look around.
I don't, not off the top of my head,
but I don't know anything about it.
(traffic noise)
The third one's the
most interesting for me.
- [Unidentified Woman]
Hello everyone. How are you?
- Hey, hi, good to see you again.
- [Gary] How are things?
Good to see you again, man.
How are you? Really good.
If I was to argue that the video we make
just happens to be a
funny video about how rad
your salespeople are, and
the KPI and the Facebook ad
is actually a phone transaction,
so it skips the steps that
you guys normally play in,
as long as that actually,
at the end of the day,
leads to a better or equal
metric to the site traffic,
even though I'm eliminating it
because I know what
these guys' magic can be.
And I also know the cult,
I don't know the culture,
but I at least know the
general sense of the vibe here.
Great. Alright. Thanks guys.
(people chat)
I'm going to see him Tuesday.
- [Unidentified Woman]
Have a good weekend.
- [Gary] Have a great weekend, brother.
Great to see you. No worries.
- [Woman] That's fine.
- [Man with Glasses] Hey, I didn't know
you were going to be here.
(woman exclaims)
Sorry, how are ya?
- [Gary] How are you?
Great to see ya.
That was fun.
- [Man with Glasses]
Tell him I got a series
of inside jokes, okay.
- Yeah, of course.
(traffic noise)
I'm not going to run,
because I don't want to run.
I need to do a call, but, like.
Hey Max and Mom.
It went really well.
You can watch some of the
footage on DailyVee 16.
That's going to be on a couple of days.
Alright. I gotta go.
I love you guys.
Uh, that wine you just bought.
I love the idea of doing
it to my list next week.
Alright man, talk to you. Bye.
(traffic noise)
Yeah. It's cool, right?
So pumped.
It's 10 years ago.
If you told me in 10 years, I'd go from
a $300 camera from Best Buy
with no lighting in my office
on this new thing called YouTube,
to you following me
around every day (laughs).
Hey, guys.
- [Unidentified Woman] Hey.
- [Unidentified Man] Hi, Gary.
- You following me around.
You following me around every day
and putting out business content.
It's an interesting decade.
("Used To" by Genesis Elijah)
Just feels good.
(people chat)
- [Unidentified Man] Is
that the (mumbles) talking?
- I was ready.
(people chat)
- Nate.
You're not going to be proud
of yourself when we go.
You're not going to be
proud of yourself when we go
lifting next time, and I dominate you.
- [Nate] Okay.
Alright.
- Noted.
(people laugh)
Mentally prepared for disappointment.
- [Voiceover] Okay,
what we do here is. Hey!
- [Together] Hey.
(people laugh through video chat)
- [Voiceover] Can you hear us now?
- [Together] Yeah.
- [AJ] We could always hear you.
- We always heard you, we always saw you.
We know everything.
Can you guys hear us?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, yeah.
- Awesome. Great.
You guys want to go through the questions
that you sent over first,
and then we'll riff
off of anything off of those questions?
- I think we have something
that's, like, doable,
but I'll just show you what it is.
And I think, oh no, what is this?
Yeah, this is it.
Um.
- Do you (words beeped out) computer?
- No. It's okay. It's...
You need to have a great computer, though.
- Well, it's due up in the summer.
- Do you want to speed that up?
- It's okay. It just--
- You do understand that you being slow
for seven minutes is probably less
valuable.
- [Man on Right] It freezes
once every four days.
- [Gary] Cool. So you're fine?
- Yeah, it's fine.
(man in checked shirt groans)
So, duh duh duh duh.
- At your value time, I
think we already should have
bought a new computer in
the last four minutes.
- It's okay.
- [Gary] That was more me
trying to--
- [Man on Right] Yeah. Um.
- [Ari] Do you guys need more time?
- We're enjoying ourselves.
- Yeah, I think we got two more minutes.
- (words beeped out) weird.
- Nothing's weird.
It's not weird, it's bad.
Weird and bad are two different things.
Have a great weekend, Ari.
- [Unidentified Man] (words
beeped out) 20 seconds.
- Ari might have a contact
and (words beeped out).
You email me the records for that break.
- Okay. How are you,
my friend?
- [Man in Purple] I'm good.
How are you?
- [Gary] It's good to see you.
Did you hear that I'm coming
up to Babson, looks like?
- [Man in Purple] No.
- It's going to be a Babson event.
- [Man in Purple] Is it?
- Yep.
- [Man in Purple] Yeah, because Alex and I
were talking about it yesterday
and then he got an email from somebody
about Babson.
- [Gary] It's going to happen.
- So it's happening? Okay.
- Awesome, man.
- [Man in Purple] Thanks.
- It's great to see you, man.
And I'll see you, I'll see you March 9th.
Or 10th. I'm going to definitely do it.
- [Man in Purple] Yes.
- It's definitely
going to happen.
- [Man in Vest] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'd like to understand
what he says about that.
- [Man in Vest] Alright.
- Alright, brother.
- [Unidentified Man] Yo.
- Yo.
Can you email me before
the end of the weekend
your personal opinion on the
three things that are moveable?
- [Unidentified Man] Yep.
- You know what I mean?
- [Unidentified Man] I do.
- Cool.
Andy.
- Super Eight Events.
This is the third client I'm
going to send to you right now.
- Okay.
I'm excited about the posters.
Okay.
Ready?
- [Woman in Navy Jacket]
Are you leaving now?
- [Gary] No.
But you're coming, right?
- [Woman in Grey Jacket] Yep.
- You didn't,
You're the only one who didn't accept.
- [Woman in Grey Jacket] I accepted.
- Now. Right.
Alright.
Jesus (words beeped out).
'Cause you're eating pizza like savages.
- [Unidentified Woman]
It's so good, Gary.
(people chat)
- [Voiceover] Right around Christmas,
when she's like, oh great.
- [Gary] So, Babson's locked in?
- [Alex] Could be.
- What do you mean?
("After Hours" by MadReal)
Alright.
- [Unidentified Man] Later, dude.
- Later, dude.
Go in the front, DRock.
And so, please.
Please, please, please understand
that I don't want anybody to do it my way.
I'm not showing you how cool
I am with my work ethic.
I'm not trying to impose
my will, go do this.
I'm not trying to take
away from your family time
or your down time.
I'm just desperately trying to share
my reality and my truth,
and because I learn by watching others.
Oh, by the way, I mainly
learn by watching others
of what I don't want to do
or how I want to do it different,
not how I want to do it.
And so I guess, for me, I'd
defaulted into showing you
the kind of naked truth of
the 24 / seven, 365 hustle.
And, that's it.
I uh, (words beeped out).
I actually secretly don't
want anybody to do it
because I know my
advantage is that I outwork
every single one of you,
and some of you are so much
more talented than I am.
Some of you are better
at building infrastructure around you.
Most of you have no interest
in this 24 / seven work ethic,
but please, please, please
also don't be confused.
I'm not sad. I'm not upset.
I love the bed that I made for myself.
I sleep in it cozy every second,
and so, what works for me
doesn't necessarily work for you.
I do me. You do you.
But, please, never, for
the rest of my life,
no matter how I roll, no
matter what I put out,
no matter where I put it out,
don't ever think I'm
trying to convince you
to do it like me.
I'm not one of these
people that are trying to,
look at me and do it
like me, buy the system.
There's no system.
There's just constant effort.
Constant.
Alright, DRock.
You've been home, probably
sleeping, for a while.
I'm just finishing up my hustle.
Heading home.
11 o'clock at night, 11:30.
Twelve.
Vayner Nation.
I love you.